- I hope that current members of Congress
recall that it actually
doesn't take a lot of courage
to aid those who are already powerful,
already comfortable, already influential.
But it does require
some courage to champion
the vulnerable and the
sick and the infirm.
Those who often have no access
to the corridors of power.
I hope they understand that courage means
not simply doing what is
politically expedient,
but doing what they believe,
deep in their hearts, is right.
And this kind of courage
is required from all of us.
Those of us who consider
ourselves progressives.
Those of us who are Democrats.
We've got some soul searching to do
to see what kind of courage we show.
We have our own dogmas.
Those of us not in elected
office have to show some courage.
We're prone to bestow
the mantle of courage
too easily on the
prominent and the powerful.
And then too eager to
wrap ourselves in cynicism
when they let us down
because they weren't perfect.
We lose sight, sometimes,
of our own obligations.
Each of ours.
All the quiet acts of courage that
unfold around us every single day.
Ordinary Americans who give
something of themselves
not for personal gain,
but for the enduring benefit of another.
The courage of a single
mom who's working two jobs
to make sure her kid can go to college.
The courage of a small
business owner who's
keeping folks on the payroll
because he knows a family relies on it.
Even if it's not always
the right thing to do
for his bottom line.
The courage of somebody who volunteers
to help some kids who need help.
When we recognize these acts of courage,
we then necessarily recognize
our own responsibility as citizens
and as part of the human family
to get involved and to get engaged
and to take a stand.
To vote.
To pay attention.